so
how did you originally start in like
this filmmaking world did you start
did you start in high school did you
start just like by grabbing a camera or
were you originally just like more like
the director writer type of
i it actually started it's so [ __ ]
weird that you're
that that we're in seminole florida
because i went to seminole high school
it's insane i graduated class of 99 and
uh
my family moved down here from new york
and uh when i was going into 11th grade
it's funny because in new york i was
getting like b's and c's
regular classes and really not going
anywhere i had nothing going for me
and i moved down here and i was put in
all honors classes i'm like what the
[ __ ] is going on teachers were taking a
liking to me
and uh we had this i had this amazing
teacher miss cameron
who just took a liking to me and was
like you should work on the on the
morning show
that we're going to start next year your
senior year and i was like cool
worked on that that was like my first
time really even messing with cameras or
anything and
i took a liking to it i think around
that time is when uh
tom green was coming out and you were
seeing him do his thing and
that freddie got fingered freddy got
fingers my favorite baby of all time
the tom green show was like hugely
influential i think to a lot of people
at the time it definitely planted a seed
with me of like getting out there
and um yeah after high school my parents
left the area and i was kind of stuck
down here on my own going to college
and uh i was totally becoming a florida
man i was
totally just becoming that kind of guy
and um
so i spent a lot of time just going out
with
my friend joe and we would just troll
the streets and
find guys to talk to i just was
stockpiling interviews not even trying
to make a movie i didn't even have that
concept in my head yet but um yeah just
just a lot of drifting around getting to
know the area getting to know people
getting to know myself through talking
to people
and through being an [ __ ] through
like doing doing pranks to people
[ __ ] i would never do now but um
yeah yeah we got the [ __ ] kicked out of
us on camera like just just pushing the
limits and
uh pushing the boundaries of
tastefulness for sure how'd you get the
[ __ ] kicked out of you
uh just outside seminal movie theater
i don't know we were filming some
[ __ ] in the parking lot and some
kids walked by and they said some [ __ ]
and we're like you guys are [ __ ]
and they were 16 we were 19 and they
just [ __ ] came over and beat the [ __ ]
out of us
oh yeah yeah we had it coming uh
yeah yeah we did we had it coming we had
it coming and we were
it's funny like we called these guys
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then uh
like you could see it on camera this guy
just slowly takes off his watch hands it
to his friends and comes over and just
knocked out my friend who was holding
the camera the camera just goes
hits the ground chaos ensues they call
the cops end up over there and while the
cops are there i'm like rewinding the
tape to where we're calling them [ __ ]
[ __ ] and like
taping over it and making sure that
there's no evidence of that part of the
whole [ __ ] thing
oh my god yeah just like a lot of stuff
like that and honestly if i hadn't
gotten out of the area
i probably would have gotten in a lot of
trouble it was it was like we were
really just
pushing the boundaries and it wasn't
like cinematic or tasteful
so yeah yeah when i got out of the area
here i went up to
um i moved it back up to new york didn't
get any film programs
um got a degree in cinema studies and uh
after school after school ended just
kind of went out into the world
not with a film degree no sense of
entitlement about making films or
anything like that just
super humble worked in a deli for a year
after college and uh
one day a dude came into the deli and
was like i think did i see you around
here with a camera one day
i was like yeah i don't know i don't i i
think
myself as a filmmaker maybe i don't know
and he's like come work for me
and that this guy's name was mark clark
and he worked for hbo and he just like
took me under his wing
and uh wow yeah i know so it's so
[ __ ] generous i think about moments
like that in my life
and it almost like gives me anxiety i'm
like what the [ __ ] if that guy never
walked in the deli that day
or didn't see me with a camera that day
or or for some reason i didn't take him
up on that
because it really led to the that led to
me working at history channel and
history channel gave me a ton of
opportunities to just go shoot stuff for
them
and good budgets to go do whatever i
wanted so i was like 23 year old kid
running around with crews and directing
stuff for history channel and uh
got enough confidence by the time i was
27 and i made my first film was called
the archive and it was just a seven
minute short
about uh the world's largest record
collection
put that on vimeo at a time where really
there was no marketplace for short films
like
no one was really just like i made a
film for the internet here it is
uh so i i benefited from that my whole
career benefited from
not a lot of people doing that at that
time yeah
and you know that that went a little bit
viral got into sundance sundance led to
me getting signed for commercial
representation and then that started
paying the bills and we just started a
cycle of
after that it was like let's make a film
every year let's really make sure we
stick to this
let's fall in love with the process and
try to fall back in love with
life through the process because i feel
like
if you can fall in love with every part
of making art you'll fall in love with
every part of life
you know not just one part of the
process or not just the glory at the end
or anything like that but like
every part of it the pain and everything
that comes along with
birthing something creative yeah
did you so when this guy first came in
he worked for hbo so you you were
just a kid in a deli that now works for
hbo no he was actually
he had a side gig making uh jerry
seinfeld's 50th birthday
video so like you know seinfeld probably
gave this guy a hundred grand to like
yeah put together something for all my
friends in the hamptons
so i was working on that in his basement
he was going down to hbo at night and he
was a producer there
and i just i kind of proved myself i
don't even know how i think i was
i just think i had the right attitude i
wasn't particularly talented at anything
i just had the right attitude i had some
initiative
like i could just see i was a good
producer at the time i could see a
couple heads
a couple steps ahead and be like uh
that's what i need to do next or
whatever just to keep them satisfied but
uh
once once i got the opportunity at
history channel they basically made me a
writer producer and i had no idea i was
just figuring it out as i went along
you know there were i had no formal
training in any of this ever
i think my work benefits from that you
know i wouldn't know how to make
like these paint by numbers for me like
documentaries i wouldn't even know where
to begin with that kind of show i'm not
interested in watching that and
i don't want to make it spend five years
of my life making [ __ ] like that
yeah for sure for sure you're uh on your
website
like some of the commercials that you've
made are insane like some of the
some of like the like just the client
like royal caribbean nest
some like really big time brands how did
you get into doing work for them
uh that's just a slowly but surely i it
actually really just came from that
first film because
um i don't i just think it had been a
while since somebody
um i just made something so perfectly
digestible that i didn't realize i was
making like a real fur
for myself like that first film was just
it was very cinematic it was well done
it was like a tear jerker and it's seven
minutes so
i think that was just right around the
time when when branded content was was
getting going and i don't know luckily i
got some attention and
you get one commercial and that leads to
another and it leads to another but i
god i i feel superstitious even talking
about commercials because it's like
so random it's always though yeah they
saw some film that he did american
juggalo or florida man and they like
want to work with him and it's like they
there's a a little bit of an
alert that happens from just like
following i think sean's passion
and just like doing what he wants and
then you know everyone wants to make
money right
well yeah definitely i mean it pays the
bills but it's also like i think we get
these jobs because we've been
so authentic in our filmmaking and the
the films are so effective that they're
like
can we pay you to do that for our brand
right once i get the job it's like
the uphill battle of all uphill battles
and it's like it's just like a month of
pain trying to make these commercials
they have to pay you a lot because
they're gonna
they're basically using your name to
legitimize a product
and and they're using my skills to make
you know to soften
their their corporate [ __ ] nastiness
and i'm like
it's just every part of it grosses me
out and i don't end up getting final cut
on them
so it drives me insane i don't even have
half my commercials on the website
because i'm just like
embarrassed about the way they came out
so i don't know what you mean
yeah yeah you know dude how often do you
do big commercial jobs like that once a
year
once a year you only do one a year it's
not even like that that's just how often
they come up this is random
yeah do you turn down a lot of them no
no no no
no no we have we have and and it's cool
it's cool to turn down a job but like
now we know they're so few and far
between we're like we're gonna take them
when they come up
and uh since we're the production
company we can make a lot more money
than when i was just a director for hire
so now google will come to us and be
like oh make something for nest and
they'll give us the whole budget we get
to hire the whole team the edit the
whole thing so
it's cool but it's a [ __ ] not a little
soul crushing that's a lot that that's
like when cass has her hands full the
most in life because she's managing the
job and then
how how much this is crushing me to even
do this
so uh yeah yeah yeah it's such a weird
thing but i'm grateful that we get to
just do this for a living
yeah absolutely